could demi lovato be released from the
hospital this week Paris Jackson sets
the record straight on her own sobriety
and Sara Bareilles dishes to me about
her next era everyone I'm Danny direct
oh this is the daily Denny it's been
nine days since Demi Lovato's apparent
drug overdose and today we're learning
she's expected to be released from the
hospital soon source tells ET Demi is
doing much better and is expected to
leave the hospital by the end of the
week she's then expected to go to rehab
addiction I would Sam Ewell says nine
days is an unusually long hospital stay
following an overdose but according to
our source the 25 year old pop star
suffered from nausea and fever which is
why doctors kept her under their care
until they were certain she was fine to
be released
we're told Demi is serious about her
sobriety so what's next I think that the
next step for her it's emotional and
physical the physical is to get through
the addictive nature to whatever drugs
she's been taking and then it's an
emotional detox that she has to be
prepared to go back into treatment to be
okay with that to fight to get back into
her recovery that's why I suggest that
she should not go home she should really
go to a 24/7 treatment center to regain
her recovery and her self-esteem
meanwhile Paris Jackson is clapping back
at claims she's going back to rehab
since Demi od'd 20 year old took to
Instagram story to set the record
straight about her own sobriety told my
friends sending me really sweet messages
letting me know that you're here for me
through a tough time or whatever I'm not
going back to rehab or clinic that was
just [ __ ] rumors online please don't
believe everything you read
Paris also responded to a fan who
tweeted about the rumor and said I don't
need a celebrity's misfortune to make me
healthy alright switching gears now to
my sit-down with Sara Bareilles the
Grammy and Tony nominated recording
artist is bringing waitress the musical
to Los Angeles at the Hollywood Pantages
Theatre
she made a splash on Broadway writing
the music for that show and went over
the TV Academy with her performance in
Jesus
Christ Superstar live so what's next for
the Triple Threat first of all I can we
just say congratulations on your Emmy
nomination I mean I know you had said
that working on Jesus Christ Superstar
was like a gift in itself but what was
your reaction when you heard getting
nominated for an Emmy I was like will I
get to hang out with Judith Light Laura
that's all I care about yeah I mean it
was remarkable it's one of those things
where it's I feel like I'm getting
invited to like somebody else's party do
you know what I'm saying like I as a
musician I feel like I'm just gonna go
be a fly on the wall and just enjoy
getting getting to be there well let's
talk about waitress the musical though
of course I mean I know it was a labor
of love and now it's in Los Angeles I
mean what has it meant to you to share
your work and this project in particular
with so many people across the country
people like me who don't get to go to
New York all the time which was always
me too as well I grew up in a small town
in Northern California I did not see
that the closest I could get to Broadway
was seeing a national tour in in San
Francisco that was the closest big city
to me to us so this is such a joy for me
to get to share this show with Los
Angeles I mean I went to UCLA I lived
here for 15 years I'm basically Lofoten
wearing a kimono what more do you want
from me it's reaching a whole new
audience and we're really getting such
wonderful feedback I mean this show has
a lot of heart a lot of humor it's
really I know it feels girly because
it's about a pie baker but like there
really is something for everybody in
this show and I'm very proud of the meal
ooh
oh you yeah music last time I spoke with
you you mentioned you we're going to be
reporting this year and I sure enough
you teased fans of video from the studio
[Music]
13 songs in oh it's it's happening
something actually happening you know
what my next question will be is when is
the first single when can we expect you
to drop something I would say
optimistically definitely before the end
of the year you're gonna hear maybe even
more than one song for the record that's
amazing yeah I know a good job you know
you love somebody talk to you're like
it's gonna happen well yeah I know
last time I was saying that to myself it
was like on the plane to LA I'm just
going like do I have two songs for a
record well I'm sure you're drawing from
a lot I mean a lot has happened in the
world and in your personal life since
that last house actually and honestly I
feel so lucky that I get to be I get to
work in a field where I get to sort of
channel my feelings about the world into
something artistic these are not these
are songs that are about the world
I got songs about Obama I got songs
about no other stuff yeah so there's
there's a little it's definitely a
slightly political record but it's
always kind of it's just about what I
want to talk about yeah yeah you know
it's what I try to do with my records is
sort of encapsulate the spectrum of what
it feels like to be alive and you know
it's the good the bad and the ugly
that's all of it yeah I love that girl
it's been five years since Sarah's last
album so I'd say it's about damn time I
can't wait
don't worry waitress the musical is
still on tour and hitting the west coast
through the end of the year all right
guys thanks for watching I will be back
tomorrow with new music - you know the
deal come back